looking to get that ideal body then it's
time to vanquish that stubborn fat with
the jazzy
tania a medical assistant from the jazzy
wellness is here to tell us how
welcome and so so first off what is
vanquish me and how does it work
our vanquish me uses radio frequency
energy to help target the fat cells to
permanently destroy them
so what areas are we treating what areas
do you guys target
we can target any areas where fat where
you have fat that you want removed so we
can do the arms the stomach the back and
the legs
and you said you said this is you we see
permanent results how is that how does
that work then
the radiofrequency energy permanently
destroys the fat cell so it all flushes
out through your lymphatic system
we're kind of seeing a sample of how
things work here on the screen right now
but so
how does the process feel it's very
comfortable the patient just
lays there and then they'll just feel a
little bit of a heat it's a small panel
that goes over the area and they just
relax for about 45 minutes
and the results are incredible how long
does each treatment take how long are
you in there for
usually 45 minutes to an hour we are
looking at some stomach results we see
the before and after
so after afterwards how long are these
results lasting then
so they're permanently the permanent the
fat cells are permanently removed
that is just i mean it's just incredible
someone's watching they're seeing these
before and after photos they want to
come and see you
do you offer a consultation where you
kind of sit down and walk through the
process with someone
yes we offer free consultations we'll go
over the whole process and make
everything more comfortable
and we're looking at this this gentleman
here is lower back you just see the
changes here and
it's it's permanent so one treatment you
get those results
yes one treatment and then over the next
few weeks you'll start to feel more of
the tightness going on
so you'll walk out of there with results
but you'll keep seeing results as the
weeks continue it's
incredible tania thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it
thank you and of course you guys always
have a great special the jazzy wellness
guarantees you will lose two inches or
more
the same day with their vanquish me
series they're offering 40
off to the first 10 callers call 702 800
746 and find them online for
jazzywellness.com
in las vegas now